-Bonjour, madame la députée.
-Vous allez bien ?
Merci de vous rendre disponible
et de venir
nous exposer où nous en sommes
sur l'érosion côtière.
-On a eu un recul
de 35 mètres
entre novembre et actuellement.
-Ce qui devient la moyenne.
-Le poste de secours,
juste derrière nous,
est à 39 mètres
de la falaise d'érosion,
donc il est menacé.
Il faudra le déplacer.
-Une nouvelle fois.
Ce poste de secours
qui a été déplacé trois fois ?
-Depuis 2010.
-Depuis 2010, ça veut dire
qu'en 20 ans,
une vingtaine d'années,
on a reculé, quoi,
pratiquement de...
-On a reculé
d'une centaine de mètres
mais c'est pas 100 mètres en 20 ans,
c'est des épisodes
très denses, très forts
sur trois, quatre ans.
-Il y a une accélération
actuellement.
J'appuie là, c'est parti ?
Allez.
Bonjour, Sophie Panonacle,
députée de Gironde
et du bassin d'Arcachon.
Nous sommes sur un territoire
extrêmement fragile,
donc je suis préoccupée
par tous ces enjeux,
ces enjeux qui touchent
l'espace marin, l'océan,
mais également nos littoraux,
et face à ce phénomène
d'érosion côtière,
de submersion.
C'est le bassin d'Arcachon.
-La côte atlantique attire toujours,
et pourtant, l'océan
la fait rétrécir un peu plus
chaque année.
Le trait de côte, cette limite
où s'arrêtent les vagues
à marée haute,
recule.
Le phénomène n'est pas nouveau,
mais il s'amplifie avec la montée
des eaux.
A quelques kilomètres d'Arcachon,
cette plage a été avalée
par les vagues,
380 mètres de moins en 50 ans.
Cédric gère la forêt
et la dune depuis 10 ans.
Il observe la plage
se métamorphoser.
-On a eu, cet hiver,
35 mètres de recul.
On a quand même eu 12 mètres
de recul en une nuit.
-C'est énorme !
-C'est énorme,
et on n'a pas eu de tempête.
Donc voilà, ça peut évoluer
vraiment très vite.
-On voit la marée qui monte
et qui vient taper, vraiment,
sur le bas de dune.
On voit bien, aussi,
l'effritement de la dune,
avec des restes de tronc
qui sont en train de tomber,
avec les racines qui sont là,
complètement à nu.
-Tout à fait. Donc là,
pour ces travaux-là, l'idée,
c'est d'éviter que les arbres
tombent sur la plage.
On exploite la forêt
sur ces bordures.
Ce qu'il en reste, puisque ça a été
touché par un incendie,
il restait une partie
qu'on a retirée
pour que ça ne tombe pas.
-Le site est très prisé.
Pour protéger
les promeneurs
quoiqu'il en coûte,
plus d'un million d'euros
ont été mis sur la table
cette année par la collectivité.
Et la facture
continue de grimper
chaque année.
-Qu'est-ce que l'on attend
de nos élus ?
C'est une aide sur la partie
réglementaire,
parce qu'on le voit, ici,
on est sur un site
qui évolue rapidement,
du fait du phénomène d'estuaire
du bassin.
Ca recule vite,
on doit s'adapter
mais d'un point de vue
réglementaire, c'est plus lent.
Pour faire une reconstruction,
c'est au minimum deux ans
de réflexion.
Et nous,
c'est un hiver d'intervention.
Si on attend deux hivers,
le poste, si on le bouge pas,
il est à l'eau.
C'est de pouvoir trouver
des moyens de s'adapter
sur des choses
vraiment très particulières.
-Ce qu'on peut apporter
en tant que législateur,
c'est des outils aux élus
pour leur faciliter la vie
et pour avoir des moyens
plus souples
d'adaptation
de nos territoires.
C'est l'objectif
de mon travail.
-La députée entame une année
bien particulière.
-Hop.
-Sophie Panonacle a été nommée
par le gouvernement présidente
de la commission du trait de côte.
La députée va sillonner
toute la France
pour trouver des réponses
à toutes ces questions.
-On continue à protéger,
on protège davantage, comment ?
On s'adapte, on relocalise,
comment, où ?
On aperçoit donc
les fameux perrés,
qui protègent
de l'érosion, qui protègent
de la montée de l'eau.
A marée haute,
l'eau s'approche quasi...
Il n'y a plus de plage.
-Non.
-L'eau va jusqu'au bord
des protections en béton.
-Le long du littoral fleurissent
ces ouvrages
car pour continuer à vivre
en bord de mer,
les propriétaires doivent
se protéger.
Ce sont leur terrain,
c'est donc à eux de payer
pour défendre leur villa.
-On voit, l'entretien se fait
en direct, on voit les grues
les camions, les pelles,
plutôt,
en train d'apporter du gravât.
-Pour garder sa maison
avec vue sur l'océan,
un homme s'est lancé
dans un projet pharaonique.
Cette digue de 450 mètres
de long,
haute de 30 mètres.
Cela fait 35 que Benoît Bartherotte
n'a qu'une obsession,
protéger son coin de paradis.
-On ne va pas attendre
que l'Etat vienne nous aider.
La défense du trait de côte,
ici, est 100 % privée.
Vous pouvez pas appeler au secours.
-Chacun défend sa propriété privée.
-C'est la loi de 1807.
-Exactement.
-Alors là, ça n'a pas l'air,
mais on a versé plus de 450 camions
depuis le 23 décembre.
Vous le voyez pas
mais il y a un pied très large,
qui est la fondation.
C'est le fameux chaînage,
avec du béton ferraillé.
Après, on en met du petit.
Les vagues le prennent
et le mettent dedans.
Et ça fait un truc souple
et armé, voilà.
Comme vous le voyez,
la digue,
j'ai commencé cette partie
depuis le pavillon
que vous voyez,
j'ai commencé
depuis janvier 94 cet allongement.
Ca n'a pas bougé.
-Si Benoît Bartherotte
n'avait pas déboursé
des millions d'euros,
sa maison aurait déjà été
engloutie.
Une lutte permanente
et il le sait,
si l'océan gagne,
il perdra tout,
sans aucune indemnisation
par l'Etat.
Alors faut-il faire évoluer
la loi ?
Comment l'Etat doit-il accompagner
les propriétaires ?
Le 3 février dernier,
en Gironde, un immeuble devient
le symbole de l'érosion.
A seulement 20 mètres de l'océan,
il est démoli.
-Il y a, en fonction
de ce que sera la réalité
du réchauffement climatique,
jusqu'à 50 000 habitations,
logements,
jusqu'à...
750 entreprises,
qui vont être concernés
à un titre ou à un autre,
des kilomètres d'infrastructures
qui vont être,
d'ici la fin de ce siècle,
concernés par cette érosion
du trait de côte.
-Après une longue bataille
judiciaire,
les 78 propriétaires
évacués de leur appartement
sont exceptionnellement
indemnisés.
Coût pour l'Etat :
7 millions d'euros.
Mais comment les habitants
peuvent-ils s'adapter
à ce trait de côte ?
La relocalisation est-elle possible
partout sur le territoire ?
Au Cap Ferret,
la députée retrouve
le maire et ce restaurateur,
installé ici
depuis trois générations.
-Le Cap Ferret fait
4 kilomètres de long
sur 1,5 kilomètre de large.
Où est-ce qu'on va
nous relocaliser ?
A Saucats, à Belin-Béliet ?
J'aime bien voir l'eau.
-C'est pas le sujet.
On en a parlé,
il y a des territoires
où on pourra relocaliser
parce que ça pourra être
envisageable.
Sur cette presqu'île
du Cap ferret,
c'est pas le sujet.
On est sur, effectivement,
la protection,
la construction de digue,
-Quelle protection vous installez ?
-C'est la difficulté.
-C'est ma question.
-Oui.
-Le danger immédiat aujourd'hui...
-On ne peut pas construire
le mur de l'Atlantique.
-4 kilomètres.
4 kilomètres.
-Trouver une stratégie,
et vite.
La députée garde en esprit
les prévisions des scientifiques.
D'après eux, d'ici 2100,
le niveau des mers aura augmenté
de plus d'1 mètre.
L'eau pénètrerait
dans les terres.
1,5 million d'habitants en France
pourrait être impacté.
Une nouvelle carte pourrait
se dessiner. En bleu,
ces zones auront disparu.
La circonscription
de Sophie Panonacle aura rétréci.
Pour certains, la relocalisation
semble inévitable.
La députée a rendez-vous
aux Flots Bleus, le célèbre camping
derrière la dune du Pilat,
qui s'érode doucement.
Après les incendies,
c'est le sable qui grignote le lieu.
Le gérant
a décidé de laisser faire
la nature.
-Nous, on s'aperçoit
que la dune,
elle glisse vers nous, doucement.
-On le voit bien, là.
On voit les arbres.
On a l'impression
qu'ils poussent sur la dune.
Ca veut dire
que tout le sable a avancé.
Là, vous avez perdu
combien ? Est-ce que vous...
Combien de mètres
en combien d'années ?
Vous êtes là depuis quand ?
-Je suis là depuis 2011.
Depuis 2011, on a dû perdre
40 à 50 mètres.
Il faut savoir qu'à une centaine
de mètres sous la dune,
il y a une piscine.
Il y a le double du camping
de l'autre côté.
Peut-être qu'un jour,
il réapparaîtra, je sais pas.
-Il s'est posé la question
de savoir s'il fallait réinstaller
des campings
ou si on profitait de ce phénomène
pour les installer
en rétro-littoral.
-Ouais, mais bon...
-C'est compliqué,
mais à la vitesse
où la dune avance,
on peut imaginer qu'un jour,
il faudra le faire.
-Déjà,
on va digérer l'incendie.
Après avoir digéré le Covid,
on va digérer l'incendie,
et après,
d'ici une dizaine d'années,
on reparlera du reste.
On a encore un peu de temps
devant nous.
Je suis très attaché
à la dune
parce que j'y suis
tous les jours, donc....
Après, aller ailleurs,
je sais pas.
On verra.
-Faudra-t-il déplacer les campings
ou les réorganiser ?
Aujourd'hui, 600 d'entre eux
sont menacés par l'érosion
et les outils juridiques
manquent.
Cet après-midi,
Sophie Panonacle réunit
les élus du bassin d'Arcachon.
-Je voudrais vraiment
vous entendre.
Vos réactions, vos remarques,
vos attentes par rapport
à ces travaux,
votre expertise, en tout cas,
de territoire.
-S'il s'agit de relocaliser,
je me tourne
vers les services de l'Etat,
qu'est-ce qui, aujourd'hui,
nous est autorisé ?
Comment on travaille pour trouver
les zones de relocalisation ?
-Aujourd'hui,
on a besoin d'avoir
des réponses un peu tranchées
de l'Etat,
qui nous permettent d'expliquer
aux gens nos décisions
ou, effectivement, les impératifs
qui nous sont imposés.
-Aujourd'hui, on est sur des travaux
à 5 ans et à 30 ans.
L'urgence, elle est absolue
et elle est maintenant.
-Il y a une solution envisagée
par la députée,
la création d'un fonds d'érosion,
une taxe additionnelle
de 0,01 %
sur les frais de notaire.
Une sorte de cagnotte
à laquelle
tous les Français participeraient
à l'achat d'un bien immobilier
pour venir en aide
aux élus du littoral.
La proposition,
si elle est retenue,
pourrait être discutée
dans le projet de loi
de finances 2024.
D'ici là, Sophie Panonacle
continue son tour de France
de la mer
en quête de solutions.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA